[Musique]
ces belles américaines étaient là bien
avant l'arrivée de fidel les cadillac
chevrolet pontiac fort des autres
marques emblématiques ont survécu à la
révolution
une soixantaine d'entre elles ont paradé
dimanche dans les rues de la capitale
cubaine
les spécialistes estiment à 60 mille le
nombre de voitures américaines encore en
circulation sur l'île
un véritable musée à ciel ouvert qui
constitue un trésor pour le pays les
vieilles voitures font partie de
l'identité cubaine
cela fait partie de notre vie
quotidienne et nous sommes heureux
qu'elle soit comme figé dans le temps
je peux voir la beauté de ces voitures
ici ce ne sont pas des voitures modernes
mais ce sont des classiques que l'on ne
trouve qu'à cuba
la longévité de ces véhicules relève du
miracle
elle est avant tout due à l'ingéniosité
à la débrouillardise des cubains cela
fait 50 ans qu'ils bichonnent leur
voiture pour continuer à rouler son
capot les gourmands v8 américains sont
souvent remplacés par des moteurs diesel
asiatiques ou soviétique
le système d qui permet de maintenir en
vie ces reliques
pour moi c'est comme un ami et
journaliste me demandais à quoi
ressemble ma voiture j'ai dit que c'est
un chien parce que le chien n'est-il pas
le meilleur ami de l'homme c'est donc
aux chiens
cette passion pour les belles
carrosseries fait la fierté de tout le
pays à la havane
c'est même devenu un atout touristique
incontestable
[Musique]